One last important statistic
on a stock that's important
is called cumulative returns.
So let's consider S&P 500,
again, back in 2012.
Now in 2012,
the S&P 500 started the year
at $125, and it ended the year at $142.
When you listen to the news
you hear things like, for
the year 2012 S&P 500 gained 13.6%.
That is cumulative return.
You don't hear them say over 2012
S&P 500 went from $125 to $142.
So how do you calculate
these cumulative returns?
It's really easy.
Here's the equation.
The cumulative return for
a particular day,
t, is just today's price divided
by the price at the beginning.
So price of zero is over here, and
the price of any particular day,
say would be here.
And we can calculate
the value like this.
Now the cumulative return for the whole
period is where t is this last day.
So let's consider
the example we've got here.
To calculate the cumulative return for
this whole year.
It's the price at the end, divided by
the price at the beginning, minus one.
Turns out 142/125 is 1.136- 1 gives
us .136 Which is equal to 13.6%.
So our cumulative return for
the ETF SPY was 13.6%.
We can calculate and chart cumulative
returns just like we did earlier for
daily returns,
except now the plot is showing us
the cumulative return of course
instead of the data return.
Note that the shape of the chart
is the same as the price chart.
It's just now it's normalized, and
in fact this equation is exactly
our normalization equation.
So that is how to calculate and
plot cumulative returns.
We're not going to have Dave show you
how to do that, you're on your own
there, now that you know how to do daily
returns, it shouldn't be that tough.
Okay, that's it for this lesson,
we'll see you again soon.